In the last video we discovered
what seems like a
problem with the Calvin Cycle.
That you have this big protein
here, enzyme, that facilitates
the Calvin Cycle.
All of the molecules that are
involved bond to this and then
it twists and turns and it jams
things together so that
they react properly.
And we know what this
is, the RuBisCo.
RuBisCo enzyme, or ribulose
bisphosphate carboxylase oxygenase.
And we know when the Calvin
Cycle operates properly you'll
have some carbon dioxide
attached in one
part of this enzyme.
And then you'll have some RuBP,
or maybe you could call
it the proper word, ribulose-1
5-bisphosphate.
And they're going to react.
And then after they react, if
everything with the Calvin
Cycle is going properly, they're
going to react and
form-- they're going to be
jammed together and then split
into-- for one molecule of that
and one molecule of that,
you're going to have
two molecules of
3-phosphoglycerate.
In the last video I started with
three of these and three
of these so I ended up
with six of these.
But for every one of these you
end up with two of these.
This is the proper
Calvin Cycle.
Then these turn into your
phosphoglyceraldehydes.
These turn into two
phosphoglyceraldehydes, or PGALs.
And then for every six of these
that are produced-- and
maybe I should write a three
here, a three here and then
I'll have six of these-- and
for every six of these that
are produced, five go back into
the cycle to produce.
So five PGALs, or glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate go
back into the cycle to produce
the ribulose bisphosphate.
And one of them is kind of our
end product of photosynthesis
that can be used to produce
other carbohydrates.
So, one PGAL.
And the whole problem, we saw
with the Calvin Cycle, is that
RuBisCo does not only
fix carbon dioxide.
That instead of carbon
dioxide we might
have an oxygen molecule.
We might have an oxygen molecule
that jumps in here.
And it can also attach to
the RuBisCo enzyme.
And in that situation, the
oxygen and the ribulose
bisphosphate react.
So if we had three ribulose
bisphosphates and three
oxygens, instead of producing
six phosphoglycerates we're
only going to produce five
phosphoglycerates and we're
going to produce five
phosphoglycolates.
Which is that byproduct that
gets processed later on.
And then these five.
You're going to have
five here.
You can't have one left over.
And then you're not going
to produce anything.
In doing this whole cycle
you have to use up a
bunch of ATPs and NADHs.
So this is a problem.
If there's a lot of oxygen
present, or even a little bit
of oxygen present, it's
going to make this a
little bit less efficient.
Because every now and then an
oxygen's going to jump in
where a carbon dioxide is needed
to actually produce an
actual carbohydrate
in the end.
So how do plants solve
this problem?
Well, one solution would be to
operate the Calvin Cycle in an
environment where there is
very, very little oxygen.
Or you can almost
say no oxygen.
And this is exactly what
some plants do.
You're like, wait,
how do I do that?
Do I have to go to a planet
where there's no oxygen?
No!
What they do is-- and to
understand this we'll have to
understand a little bit of
the actual make-up of
the leaf of a plant.
And that doesn't hurt because
everything we've been doing
now has been biochemistry.
it's nice to see leaves.
So if I draw-- let's say
that that is a leaf.
That is a leaf.
I can make it look
nice like a leaf.
That's a nice looking leaf.
On your leaf's surface, and
actually on both sides of it,
you have these little pores,
these little holes on the
leaf's surface.
They are actually surrounded
by these things
called guard cells.
But the important thing is that
these little pores-- and
they're actually much smaller
than that; you'd have to get a
microscope to actually see
them-- they're called stomata.
Or one individual of
these pores or
holes is called a stoma.
And this is where the oxygen
and the-- mainly the carbon
dioxide-- but this is where the
air enters the cell and
this is actually where
water vapor is also
released from the cell.
If we draw a cross section of
a leaf, so let me do my best
to draw a cross section
like this.
Let me draw it like that
and maybe that's the
bottom of the leaf.
This would be my stoma.
This is the actual opening.
This is the actual opening and
plants can actually open and
close their stomata.
The plural of stoma
is stomata.
They can open and close
their stomata.
But the important thing to
realize is what's going on
inside the cell.
So most plants, you have this
whole photosynthetic process,
or photosynthesis process,
occurring in these mesophyll
cells, which are really just
these middle layer cells.
And I'll do a detailed video
in the future about the
anatomy of a plant.
But these are the
mesophyll cells.
This is where photosynthesis
normally occurrs.
And because they use carbon
dioxide, or they need air--
actually I drew it wrong.
Let me draw it a little
bit better.
There's actually space
between them, so that
air can get to them.
There's mesophyll, I'm doing
a very rough drawing.
But in this situation air can
enter through a stoma and then
it can fill the space between
these mesophyll cells and it
can provide air to the
mesophyll cells.
And when I say air, that air is
made up of carbon dioxide
and oxygen and nitrogen
and all the things
that are in our air.
And of course, it needs the
carbon dioxide to actually
perform the Calvin Cycle.
Now, we just said that it's
not just getting CO2.
If it was just getting CO2
you wouldn't worry about
photorespiration.
It's also getting oxygen.
It's also getting molecular
oxygen.
So what can the plant to
do to prevent this?
And not all plants-- you know,
most plants just deal with
photorespiration.
It's just a little less
efficient than the ideal.
But some plants have-- I guess
we could say-- evolved past
the photorespiration problem.
And these are called
C-4 plants.
Or they perform C-4
photosynthesis.
And we'll understand, hopefully
in a few minutes,
why it's called C-4.
Just as a reminder, when we go
up to the mechanism up here.
The classic Calvin Cycle, the
first byproduct is this
phosphoglycerate, this
is a 3-carbon chain.
So it's saying that the first
time that you fix carbon
dioxide, or actually the first
time you fix carbon dioxide or
oxygen, but let's say the first
time you fix carbon
dioxide you end up with a
3-carbon chain molecule.
That's why this is called
C-3 photosynthesis.
So, that's a clue.
On C-4 plants, the very first
time that they fix carbon
dioxide they must end up with
a 4-carbon molecule.
And what they do-- and this is
the interesting thing-- is you
have all your mesophyll cells
that are out here.
They're getting air.
They're getting carbon
dioxide.
You know, they're getting carbon
dioxide and they're
getting oxygen and
whatever else.
So you have all your mesophyll
cells that are getting air.
But you also have cells that
are deeper within, more
embedded within the leaf that
aren't being exposed directly
to the air coming through
the stomata.
So you have these bundle-sheath
cells.
And these are actually the cells
that surround the actual
pipes in the plant that
distribute the fluid up and
down the plant.
And we'll do a whole video on
the anatomy of the plant.
I really just want you to
understand what's going on in
C-4 photosynthesis.
So you have these other cells
that are more embedded.
They don't have direct
access to the air.
So these are bundle-sheath
cells.
And what these plants do is,
the carbon dioxide comes in
and-- so in the standard Calvin
Cycle, everything
happens in the mesophyll cells
and you have to deal with
photorespiration.
In your C-4 plant, or your
plants performing C-4
photosynthesis, what happens
is the carbon dioxide comes
in-- so this is in the
mesophyll cell.
Let me be neat about it.
So in our mesophyll cell, that's
that right there, you
have CO2 coming in
and it reacts.
Instead of reacting with RuBP
or ribulose bisphosphate, it
reacts with another very hairy
sounding compound, we'll just
call it PEP.
But it's phosphoenolpyruvate
So that's PEP.
You just have to remember,
it is a 3-carbon chain.
Now let me write down the word,
because sometimes you
might want to know, what
does PEP stand for?
It's phosphoenolpyruvate or
phosphoenolpyruvic acid Either way.
3-carbon molecule, it's got
other stuff hanging off of
this but we just have to
remember the carbons.
So when these two react what are
you going to end up with?
Well you could guess.
You have one carbon, you
have three carbons.
You're going to end up with
a 4-carbon molecule.
And this reaction right here
is facilitated, not by
RuBisCo, ribulose bisphosphate
carboxylase oxygenase.
It's facilitated by a
different enzyme.
And this is the key.
This is the key for C-4.
This is a different enzyme.
This is called PEP
carboxylase.
Let me write it down.
PEP carboxylase.
And that's a fitting name.
Remember, RuBisCo or ribulose
bisphosphate carboxylase, it
reacted ribulose bisphosphate
with carbon or oxygen.
That's where that oxygenase
comes from.
But now we have something
that reacts PEP, our
phosphoenolpyruvate with
carbon dioxide.
So it's called PEP
carboxylase.
Actually this is carboxylase,
not carboxylate.
It's an enzyme.
This is PEP carboxylase.
And what's special about PEP
carboxylase, and why it's
useful in preventing
photorespiration, is that it
can only fix carbon.
Not oxygen.
So you can imagine, this
is occurring in
the mesophyll cell.
You have oxygen and carbon
dioxide running around here.
But only carbon dioxide can
react with the PEP via the PEP
carboxylase.
So then they react, they
actually produce oxaloacetic
acid or oxaloacetate And you
might remember this from the
Kreb Cycle.
This was the thing that was the
first reactive species in
our Kreb Cycle.
So all of these molecules, they
keep showing up in our
chemical pathways.
And that's interesting if you
find that type of thing
interesting.
But the important thing is,
they form oxaloacetate and
then oxaloacetate
gets converted.
Let me make it, I made
this not as neatly as
I would like to.
But then that gets converted to
either malate or aspartate
but these are all 4-carbon
molecules.
They're a little different;
they're going to have
different oxygens and hydrogens
hanging off of them.
But this is either malate
or aspartate
Most books will just say, oh it
will eventually just form
into malate only.
And then this, this malate, will
then essentially react to
produce carbon dioxide.
And you're like, wait.
That doesn't make sense.
I have carbon dioxide, it gets
fixed on oxaloacetic acid and
then it gets turned into malate
or aspartate And then
later I'm going to turn into
carbon dioxide again.
What's the whole point?
And this is the key.
This is the whole crux
of the issue.
So now this malate is going to
be converted back into PEP and
carbon dioxide.
You're like, what was
the whole point
of this whole reaction?
I just ended up with carbon
dioxide and PEP again.
I'm just going in circles.
But the neat thing about this,
and the reason why this
prevents photorespiration is
that this part, this part of
the reaction right here-- maybe
I should do it like
this-- this part of the
reaction occurs in the
mesophyll cell.
It occurs up here.
It occurs over here in
the mesophyll cell.
So you have this malate.
And then the malate actually
gets transferred into these
bundle-sheath cells.
So the malate gets transferred
into the bundle-sheath cells
via little tubes that connect
the cells called plasmodesmata
Sounds like the name
of a horror movie.
So let me draw this a
little bit neater.
So over here you have, with
exposure to the air, you have
your mesophyll cell.
Air is coming in, O2, CO2,
everything is coming in.
But only CO2 can be
fixed with PEP.
So you have the PEP here, the
phosphoenolpyruvate So you
have your Pep here.
Only CO2 can be reacted with
PEP because of the PEP
carboxylase.
This is the enzyme
that's operating.
So this is much more specific
than the ribulose bisphosphate
carboxylase, or the RuBisCo.
So the oxygen just
gets ignored.
Even though it's hanging around
these mesophyll cells.
And then these, this
gets converted.
Oxaloacetic acid.
And then to malate.
But once it gets converted to
malate, the malate gets
transferred deeper into the
actual cell via these
plasmodesmata So this might be
butting right up against
bundle-sheath cell, that's
deeper in the cell.
This bundle-sheath cell has
no access to oxygen.
So the malate comes in.
You have these little pipes
that connect the cell.
Maybe I'll just draw one pipe.
So let's say there's one pipe.
So the malate can come here.
And then, within this deeper
cell, within this
bundle-sheath cell, it can
then react to form carbon
dioxide and pyruvate.
And then the pyruvate--
so let's just
say this is the pyruvate.
That pyruvate can then later
go back to actually
form the PEP again.
So this can go back through
your plasmodesmata
and form the PEP.
So the whole value here is, now
in the bundle-sheath cell,
I have an environment that
only has carbon dioxide.
I have no oxygen here.
I was able to essentially
select for the
carbon dioxide outside.
Or closer to the air in
the mesophyll cell.
And now that I'm deeper within
the plant, I'm in an
environment that only has CO2,
because I've already
selected for it.
And now I can perform
the Calvin Cycle.
So now, inside this deeper
cell, inside this
bundle-sheath cell, I can fix
the carbon dioxide with the
ribulose bisphosphate using
RuBisCo, just like we learned
in the original Calvin Cycle.
And we have the whole cycle
and we produce our sugars.
We produce our
phosphoglyceraldehydees or our
PGALs, whatever you
want to call them.
And the whole value this is,
that we were able to avoid the
photorespiration problem.
Because now the Calvin Cycle is
occurring in an environment
that only has carbon dioxide.
And I think I already mentioned
it, but this is
called C-4 photosynthesis.
And it's an adaption to make
sure that you don't waste
cycles of your Calvin Cycle
through photorespiration.
And of course it was called C-4,
because the first time
that carbon gets fixed
it doesn't happen
in the Calvin Cycle.
It happens up here, with
PEP carboxylase.
And it gets fixed with PEP
into a 4-carbon chain.
And that's why it's called
C-4 photosynthesis.